Ready?
Expanding Career and Technical
Education, or CTE, is one of today's most
popular education policy issues. But
who's been taking these courses? CTE
course taking has seen a 30-year decline.
Business courses are the major driver.
Why? Mostly from the drop in typing
classes since the 80s. Take away business,
and course taking is flat. But there's
more. While traditional vocational
concentrators and subjects like
agriculture and manufacturing have
declined a little, new era concentrators —
those in health care or computer science —
have increased dramatically. These two
groups differ notably. On test scores and
college-going, traditional concentrators
are below average, while new era
concentrators look average. CTE no longer
fits 80s stereotypes. Concentrators'
average outcomes have been rising, but is
it because programs are improving, or
because they're serving more academic
students? For CTE to be successful,
leaders must not only ensure programs
are meeting targeted outcomes, but also
that they target the students who need
them the most.
Do you agree? Are CTE programs reaching
the students that need them the most?
Let us know in our poll. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.